la leche de fórmula para bebé se empieza
a desaparecer de las estanterías de eeuu
se trata de un importante sustituto de
la leche materna para bebés cientos de
familias temen que en los próximos días
se les agote lo último que les queda
para alimentar a sus hijos las más
afectadas son las familias de bajos
recursos que no tienen forma de acceder
a las fórmulas
pienso en los padres que tal vez su bebé
tiene que tomar una cierta fórmula
sensible o algo muy específico y no
pueden encontrarla como he visto en
facebook donde la gente está muy
desesperada porque necesita esta marca
específica
precisamente jennifer de 36 años cuenta
que justo antes de que se le acabara el
último envase público su situación en
redes sociales y alguien les regaló unas
cuantas latas es una locura es como
cuando todo el mundo ha buscado papel
higiénico y desinfectante y de repente
desapareció de los estantes creo que
mucha gente gracias a la inflación dice
sabes que voy a salir a comprar fórmula
y acumularla en mi casa o la gente la
está comprando y vendiendo por el doble
o triple en línea una de las causas de
la escasez es la alteración en la cadena
de distribución en una variedad de
productos debido a la pandemia de kobe
19 a lo que se sumó la pausa en la
producción tras haber detectado una
bacteria contaminante en el producto por
lo que las autoridades sanitarias
advierten a los padres que no diluyen la
leche para hacerla rendir por la escasez
algunas farmacias restringieron la
compra sólo tres latas y el gobierno del
presidente joe biden aseguró que está
trabajando para lograr incluir dentro de
los programas sociales diferentes marcas
extranjeras de leche de fórmula para
hacerle frente a la problemática